There were a couple of areas that have been
discussed a little bit, which I wanted to
elaborate on because I think it is significant.
One of them relates to intact aborts.
The question of a crew escape system and whether
that should be automated, whether the crew
should have control and what is required if
you actually have the crew take control.
I think Chris Kraft gave an interesting perspective
with the idea that because of the difficulties,
or given the requirements, really, the impossibility
of incorporating a capsule escape system for
the Shuttle, the project basically took the
point of view that the Shuttle itself was
the escape pod, which means that you have
to recover the Shuttle intact regardless of
any engine failures.
Now that, of course, requires 100% reliability
of the solid rocket boosters which we never
did achieve with Challenger.
Although, of course, had we operated it within
its spec limits it might be another story.
But, in any case, I want to go through some
of the details of a return to launch site
abort and then I will describe an incident
which occurred on our last flight to give
you an idea of what is involved in the actual
operation of abort modes.
The idea is you have the two solid rocket
boosters which have to light.
And they are going to perform no matter what.
If one of those boosters doesn't light and
the other does it is a bad day.
What can you say?
And, obviously, if one of them fails during
flight it is a bad day.
And, which was more of a design problem, if
they don't tail off at just the identical
rate so that you get asymmetric thrust greater
than a certain capability of the Shuttle to
control, you have had a bad day.
And because of the requirement to have symmetric
thrust, I don't think if this was discussed
before, when the solid rocket boosters are
poured, they mix a batch of propellant sort
of like you mix bread dough.
And then they pour the propellant into both
the left and the right booster segments at
the same time so each booster segment has
the identical batch of propellant in it.
It may not be the same from the bottom to
the top, but it is the same from the left
to the right.
And that is critical.
And then they always reserve a certain proportion
of the propellant.
And they do tests on that to make sure that
there are no process control problems.
OK.
You still need the three main engines to have
enough thrust.
The boosters each give you about 2.5 million
pounds thrust, so that is about five million
pounds to get off the ground.
These give you about a half a million pound
thrust at vacuum, four hundred and some odd
thousand pounds thrust, so still over a million
pounds thrust.
And, of course, the problem you have during
first stage is you have big gravity losses.
The Shuttle on the pad weighs about 5.5 million
pounds with all the propellant.
If you don't fire your main engines you are
barely going to lift off the ground.
Actually, I guess it is a little bit less
than five million pounds.
But, in any case, without the three main engines
firing you don't have enough thrust to get
into orbit.
Now, remember we talked about for deorbit
burn, normally we fire both OMS engines.
If one of the OMS engines is out you can fire
one engine for twice as long.
Or, if they are both out, you can fire the
four RCS thrusters for twice as long again.
Because you are in orbit, you are weightless,
you don't have gravity losses, so firing half
as many engines for twice as long is completely
equivalent.
When you are taking off against gravity that
is not true.
I mean if you only have five million pounds
of thrust for a five million pound payload
you are just going to sit on the pad and burn
all your fuel.
OK.
You need your three engines.
And, in fact, another interesting point, the
attachment between the external tank and the
Shuttle, that is stressed to assume that you
have at least one engine burning.
They tell me that if the Shuttle took off
with just the solid boosters and you didn't
have any thrust, sort of keeping the Shuttle
up with the external tank, that the structural
attachment points would fail.
Anyway, you need your engines.
What happens if you lose an engine early on?
If you are far enough into the launch, you
are over the main gravity loss segment usually
starting at about 3.5 to 4 minutes into launch.
If you lose one engine you can make it over
the ocean, And that is called a Trans-Atlantic
Abort.
And, when you do that, you are basically flying
upside down.
You will do a roll maneuver, drop your external
tank and come in and land.
And you are basically going in the same direction
which is nice when you are flying a rocket.
These things are hard to turn around.
But if you are going to do a return to launch
site abort that is exactly what you have to
do.
So, this is a procedure that has been analyzed
to death in many, many computer simulations.
The basic procedure is you take off and you
lose an engine.
Now, it doesn't matter when you lose an engine
in the first 2.5 minutes.
You don't do anything while the solid rocket
boosters are firing.
They basically have open loop guidance.
There is a certain projector programmed in
and you cannot readjust that trajectory with
a closed loop guidance solution to accommodate
for any sort of a malfunction.
So, you don't even declare an RTLS abort.
And that, by the way, is done by the crew
punching a button which essentially is a protected
button.
You punch that.
And you can also do it via a computer input
if something goes wrong with the button.
You declare an RTLS abort after SRB separation.
Immediately what happens is your trajectory
increases because you want to gain altitude,
and you will see why in a minute.
But what happens now is you've got a pretty
hefty downrange velocity already and you have
got to turn around and come back.
You have also got to worry about the disposal
of your external tank.
If you turn around and you come back, you
are still burning your engines, you are still
riding your tank, and you don't want the tank
coming down on Melbourne or Disney World or
anything like that.
The basic procedure is as follows.
You are going out, you loft your trajectory
a bit, once you get far enough out now what
you do is you do a powered pitch around.
A very sporty maneuver.
The external tank is here.
Now you are flying backwards into your plume
and everybody has speculated on what that
would actually look like.
Now you are flying backwards decelerating.
And, as you decelerate, of course, gravity
is starting to push you down so you've got
to increase your pitch velocity until finally
you basically have no more horizontal velocity
and are just sitting statically on top of
your exhaust.
And now you gradually pitch forward and you
start to fly back.
Again, you have got to plan your trajectory
so that when you drop the tank it is going
to come down in the ocean.
And then, if all that goes well, now you enter
the heading alignment circle.
And, of course, you are a heavy weight vehicle
because you also, in the process of the RTLS,
dump your OMS tanks and your RCS propellant
so that you want to make sure you are as light
as possible.
Plus, in case you have any problem with landing
you don't want your hypergolic propellant
tanks to rupture.
If all that goes well, now you enter the heading
alignment circle and you have hopefully a
nominal landing.
As I say, this has been analyzed in high-fidelity
dynamic simulations.
The crew practices it over and over again.
Everybody knows the procedures.
Nobody wants to be the first crew to try this
out.
Before STS-1, you remember we talked about
how there were lots of problems with the tiles
falling off.
I remember one of the people very high up
in NASA, I don't remember if it was the administrator
or one of the deputies, suggested that maybe
the safest thing to do would be to do a planned
RTLS because an RTLS, of course, you don't
get up to those high velocities.
And so you don't have any thermal problems.
And so if a whole bunch of tiles had fallen
off on the launch pad you could safely do
an RTLS.
Well, obviously, they did not appreciate the
difficulties of doing an RTLS and that suggestion
was not taken up.
We basically decided we were not going to
fly until we had confidence that the tiles
were going to stay on.
Cut forward to February of 1996, which was
my fifth and final Shuttle flight.
I was the second flight engineer so I was
sitting right behind the pilot who is responsible
for the main engine performance.
Now, I should tell you, we have had, in the
course of the 114 Shuttle flights we have
had four pad shutdowns, pad aborts.
And I think we talked about that briefly.
The main engines turn on six seconds before
the solids.
Just reviewing that does two things.
It gives the engines time to come up to full
thrust and then you can perform checks on
them to make sure that they are operating
properly before you commit yourself to flight.
And, of course, it gives time, because of
the asymmetric thrust, for what we call the
"twang" that the whole Shuttle stack goes
forward and then back.
And then, when you get to the vertical, you
light the boosters.
In fact, when they had the first test firing
on the pad before STS-1, one of the reasons
that they wanted to do that, in addition to
just confirming that everything was working
right, is they really wanted precise timing
on the twang.
People had calculated it, but that is not
something you want to get wrong.
So, they wanted an experimental verification.
Of the four pad shutdowns, two of them were
caused by instrumentation and two of them
were real engine problems.
I remember the first one was the last flight
before what would have been my first flight
back in 1984.
And the main engine cutoff is called MECO.
So, 8.5 minutes into the flight.
After they had a pad abort the flight engineer
called to Mission Control we have MECO, somehow
I thought we would be a little bit higher.
And, of course, when that happens now you've
got to pull all the engines out, take them
back to the shop, bring in new engines and
it is about a two or three week stand down.
And the crew has to go back to Houston.
And, of course, all of your friends and family
are there and they have to go home.
It is no fun.
I mean nobody complains if it is safe.
We're sitting on the pad, we're counting down
and everything was on schedule.
In fact, the first of my five flights it had
zero problems, zero delays.
We were going on the day that was predicted
on the time.
Countdown to six seconds.
You can feel the engines.
Everything starts to rumble.
The engines start up.
There is what we call a steam gage, a vertical
bar which shows the engine power.
Center and right engines come up to 100%.
The left engine comes up to 40%.
The pilot calls out left engine at 40%.
In times like this, your mind is working pretty
fast.
I remember thinking to myself oh, damn, we
are going to have a pad shutdown, we have
got to go back to Houston and back to the
simulators.
I mean stupid things to be thinking about
at that time, but that is sort of the way
it works.
And all of a sudden kaboom.
I feel this big kick in my back.
The solids have lit.
What in the hell is going on?
We were supposed to have a pad abort.
Now we are going with an engine.
And, actually, when you are going through
maximum dynamic pressure, max q, the engines
throttle down to about 65%.
And there is a malfunction if one of your
engines gets stuck it is called getting stuck
in the thrust bucket.
If it doesn't come back to full power you
are RTLS abort.
Well, we were taking off with one engine at
40%.
It sort of dawned on me that we were going
to be the first crew to do an RTLS, so at
that point I start going through my checklists.
And the pilot calls to the ground we have
ignition, left engine at 40%.
And so, for about the first 15 seconds or
so, I just had barely time to get out the
RTLS checklist and start getting ready to
read the procedures.
And then it turns out that the ground has
more insight than the crew does.
And it turns out that there are several sensors,
one of which feeds that gauge.
But, in fact, that sensor had gone bad.
And, in fact, the left engine was performing
nominally and the ground was able to confirm
that both by the other sensors and by looking
at the acceleration.
And so, everything was OK, I put away the
checklist and enjoyed the ride.
But, first of all, it was kind of a scary
situation.
But it also shows the difficulty.
Now, suppose we, as the crew, had been responsible
for declaring an abort.
If you are going to build in a system where
this is the crew's responsibility then you
better design your instrumentation so that
the crew has all the instrumentation required
to make that decision correctly.
Similarly, if this were to be an automatic
abort, you've got to have failure detection,
identification, reconfiguration.
The last thing you want is to go into an abort
situation when you don't have to because there
is no way that an abort is going to be anywhere
near as safe as a nominal mission.
Obviously, it's just a good story now.
But I think it does have something to inform
about how you are going to have to design
abort systems.
And, as both Aaron Cohen and Chris Kraft said,
although the astronauts always felt comfortable
with their abort system but I am not sure
that all the people in Mission Control were
quite so comfortable knowing the things that
might go wrong with it.
And, in fact, as he said, they always breathe
a sigh of relief after first stage when the
abort rocket would detach and fire itself
away.
Yeah.
If one of the engines is not working or not
working properly, I guess the other two engines
try to do the work [NOISE OBSCURES].
Well, they certainly will throttle up to 109%
if they need to, but they cannot make up for
the first engine when you're in the first
stage and you have lots of gravity losses.
In fact, when you get, like I said, to about
3.5, 4 minutes then you have enough altitude
and downrange velocity to make it across.
And then at some point you get to the situation
where you basically gained your altitude.
And, although you are not at orbital velocity
yet so you still have some gravity losses,
the gravity losses are small enough that if
you have a loss of an engine you can still
make it to a lower orbit.
That is called abort to orbit, ATO.
And you will hear the call press to ATO means
that you can now make it to a lower orbit
which is the safest thing to do with two engines.
And then a little bit later on you will hear
like single engine TAL which means if you
lose two engines with only one engine you
can make it across the Atlantic.
And then later on you will hear single engine
ATO and then finally single engine.
Then you will also hear press to MECO which
means at this point if you lose an engine
you can make it through your nominal orbit.
And usually about the last call a single engine
press to MECO which means even if you lose
two engines you can still make it to MECO.
What happens then if there
is an instrumentation problem [NOISE OBSCURES]?
The crew will never declare an abort on their
own because it is just realized that the ground
has so much more information.
The only exception is if you lose comm.
If we had lost comm.
and we saw our engine at 40%, I mean there
were a few other displays which the pilot
was starting to call up.
And it could be that he would have figured
it out perhaps, perhaps not, but that is the
only circumstance under which the crew would
make that call.
There was abort at some stage.
What happened to that?
Did they manage to make it [OVERLAPPING VOICES]?
I was trying to remember.
Did I talk about that in class?
Well, all right, I will run through that because
it was, again, a very interesting story.
The things that you are afraid about is that
if things go back in a hurry in an engine
that an engine can actually blow up.
And it is one thing if an engine gets shutdown.
Now you are just flying on two engines.
But if an engine blows up and takes out your
whole rear section you have had a bad day.
The instrumentation is biased towards an early
shutdown.
If you sense that something has gone wrong
shut it down.
We have got intact aborts.
Better to err on the side of safety, even
if that might potentially put you into an
abort situation.
And I am trying to exactly reconstruct it.
The thing is that if you lose one engine now
you are abort ATO.
Now, if you lose a second engine you might
be in a situation where certainly you cannot
make it to orbit.
And, because you have changed your trajectory,
you might not be able to make it to a good
Trans-Atlantic landing site.
So, at that point, if you have lost one engine
there is a switch on the center console where
you can override the engine shutdown command.
What you are now saying is we are in an unsurvivable
situation if we only have one engine.
And, therefore, we will take the extra chance
of getting an instrumentation caused engine
shutdown.
We are not going to take that chance so we
are going to disable the ability of instrumentation
to shut down the engine and we will just take
our chances.
The ground will continue the calculation.
And, as soon as you get to the point where
you have the capability of doing a single
engine TAL or a single engine abort to orbit,
you re-enable the instrumentation.
What happened is the Shuttle launched.
It must have been about 4 or 5 minutes into
launch because they lost an engine, it shut
down automatically, they are now abort to
orbit lower orbit, but they were abort to
orbit.
Take the switch, put it to inhibit.
Now, the main propulsion flight controller
was very good.
She realized right away that it was an instrumentation
problem because sometimes you can see certain
trends or you see things change in a way that
tells you that this is not the way a real
engine behaves, that this is more typical
of instrumentation.
She suspected she had an instrumentation problem.
Now they get a little further along in the
launch where they could have potentially done
-- They were too far to land in the normal
TAL sites which were in the daytime on the
West Coast of Africa, but they could have
made a nighttime landing at some emergency
airport in the Congo, I think it was, if they
had lost another engine.
But, by the flight rules, they take the switch
back to enable so that now, because you can
"safely" lose a second engine you want to
protect yourself against an explosive situation.
So, now they are enabled.
Now the flight controller sees that the instrumentation
on one of the other two engines is starting
to go back the way the first one was.
And she realized that in about 15 seconds
that engine was going to shut down so she
immediately called the flight director and
said flight, take the switch back to inhibit.
And this is where the discipline becomes very
important, luckily flight didn't get into
a long involved discussion about why do you
want to do that, what is going on, but just
said CAPCOM engine switch to inhibit.
They took it.
And sure enough the instrumentation went bad
but the engine was OK.
They got to orbit.
Then they used some of their OMS propellant
to raise their orbit a little bit.
That was a Spacelab mission.
And they had a good mission.
But the flight controller actually won a big
award for that because she really saved the
day.
So, yeah, that is the closest we ever came
to a real intact abort.
Yeah.
Two questions.
The first one is going back to the return
to launch site.
Do all of the main engine propellant get used
up before the tank gets dropped or do you
not burn some of the propellant?
You know, I don't know the answer to that.
I don't.
And the other one is on the pad, with your
flight, wouldn't the sequencing computer shut
down the other engines if it detected that
one of them had failed?
And so it must have used the good sensor.
Yeah, that is right.
And, luckily, our little gauge was just fed
by one.
And, in retrospect, you can say probably that's
not a good way to design it but that is the
way it was designed.
You're right.
If the engine controller senses with a majority
or however they program it, I don't know the
details of the guts of the software there.
But if it is convinced that one of the engines
is not working right it shuts down all three
engines, which is what happened on four occasions.
Yeah.
When you talked about the forced pitch over
in the return to launch site, was that just
the gambling of the main engines that gives
you that?
Yeah, because you are off the solids at that
point.
And that is the thing.
I mean with the solids there is such an enormous
thrust and the aerodynamic loads are huge.
You don't want to deviate from your planned
trajectory because one of the things that
they do is program in load relief for the
aerodynamic surfaces.
They take the day of winds launch.
And, if you have wind shears or other atmospheric
high jet streams that you are going to fly
through, they actually program the elevons
and the body flap to move in such a way as
to relieve the aerodynamic loading on the
wings.
And that is preprogrammed in.
It is not a closed loop.
It is totally open loop so you don't want
to change the trajectory once you've put all
that load relief in.
How long does that take?
It's pretty quick.
It's about ten seconds, if I remember from
the simulator.
It is a sporty maneuver, I will tell you.
No RCS that goes into that?
Oh, the RCS is trivial compared to what you're
getting out.
You've got 500,000 pounds coming out of each
engine.
The primary RCS is 750 pounds.
But, like I said, they do then open up the
RCS as you are flying back.
And what they do is they open up all the engines
so that you have symmetrical thrusts so that
you are firing out of both sides.
The idea is just to deplete the tanks as much
as possible.
The second technical area that I had been
hoping that Al Louviere would get into and
didn't have a chance to was the payload bay
doors which are a fascinating mechanism.
And it is also going to be a segue into EVA
because it was a strange situation.
It is kind of relate back to that now when
you look at how many successful EVAs have
been done and the Hubble repair and the building
of Space Station and all the other things,
but management at Johnson Space Center was
not particularly friendly to EVA back in the
`70s.
I asked Chris Kraft about that.
At first he denied it.
He said well, I always liked EVA.
He said well, maybe it was the management
of the Astronaut Office that didn't like EVA.
He did admit that Bob Gilruth who was the
Director of Johnson Space Center at the time,
this was when Chris Kraft was head of flight
operations, definitely did not like EVA.
He was afraid of it.
He didn't think it was safe, despite the fact
that back in 1973 EVA had saved the entire
Skylab project.
Hopefully most of you know that story.
I know it is ancient history.
And clearly we had done a lot of safe EVAs
on the surface of the Moon, but basically
EVA was looked at it was expensive, it was
potentially hazardous.
Given the things that the Shuttle was supposed
to do in the original planning, mainly launch
satellites, launch pieces of the Space Station,
that went away, Launch Defense Department
satellites, commercial satellites, EVA was
not really part of the big picture in planning.
And, although they did design an airlock for
the Shuttle, there were real questions of
how much preparation do we have to do for
EVA?
Do we really even need it?
Maybe we could save some weight by not having
space suits aboard.
That is
where we finally ended up.
That is the Hubble Telescope.
This is the side of the payload bay.
I mean, obviously, EVA became a very successful
activity.
These are the payload bay doors.
This is in the orbiter processing facility.
And one of the things, well, I have a picture
of closing the door.
But the mechanism of these doors is extraordinary.
There are two motors, one at the front and
one at the back of each.
Each of the motors has two drive units and
they work through a differential so that if
one of the motors fails the other one can
still drive although at half the speed, just
similar to the way a car works.
There is a long torsion rod which runs the
length of the Shuttle.
And then that torsion rod is attached to these
bars over here.
And I am sorry the picture was scanned in
and is not terribly sharp.
As the torsion bar twists then these rods
lift up the payload bay door and bring it
to a close.
The mechanism, this is the best picture I
could find, you notice there is a strong back
because, as was mentioned, the doors cannot
support their own weight in 1G.
But the system of latches here, you have to
remember that the payload bay can expand and
contract by several inches due to thermal
environment.
And so you have to design a latch system that
can accommodate this thermal behavior.
It was an incredible mechanical challenge.
And the complexity of this system, I mean
I am always amazed when I look at how the
thing works.
I have a schematic of them later, which you
can look at, but basically you close the doors.
And then the first thing you do is you want
to close the latches on either end.
And then there is also center line latches.
And I think Al Louviere did discuss the fact
that these payload bay doors are part of the
structural element of the Shuttle during reentry.
You cannot reenter if the doors are not just
closed by latched.
You need them latched for structural strength.
There is a series of bollards here, little
protrusions which these latches grab on.
And they have designed the rigging of the
rods such that the latches that are close
to the hinge line actually close before the
latches that are further away.
It is a sequential closing of the latches
all with a single mechanism so that basically
you pull the part of the door that is closest
to the torque rod, you latch that down first,
and then it is kind of a zipper effect where
then you pull it down so that even if the
door is a little bit warped thermally you
will get the door to close properly.
You wouldn't want to close this latch first
and then have the door in a situation where
it was buckled out.
And then, of course, the center line latch,
because of the thermal expansion, you can
have the doors coming together like that or
like that.
And you have got to have centerline latches
that can accommodate for that.
It is really quite an incredible design.
And Al Louviere had said that he was going
to talk about it, but he didn't have time
to.
There is plenty of redundancy in here because
there are these double motors, but because
this is so critical people started to look
at suppose you have some degree stuck in the
mechanism, it doesn't matter how many motors,
you cannot get it closed.
Suppose the motors jam on one side.
Now the other motor is not going to be able
to drive it.
So, various things were done to allow for
EVA intervention.
And, in the early Shuttle flights, this was
the only thing that the crew trained for with
EVA, it was just payload bay door contingencies.
For instance, the PDU, the drive unit, this
is the payload bay door drive unit or PLBDU.
That is what we call a nested acronym.
That is part of the game there.
You have to go out and actually peel away
the liners of the payload bay.
And inside here there is a little mechanism
where you can insert a special tool and twist
it.
And that actually disconnects that motor drive
unit from the torque so that it can turn freely.
And I hope, when you look at these things,
you will get some sense of the complexity
of these mechanisms.
And so what we do for training -- Of course
they build mockups of this in the water and
we also look at the real Shuttle down in Florida
to actually see these units.
And, for the people who are on the EVA crew,
you spend a lot of time crawling around the
payload bay getting intimately familiar with
a lot of the actual mechanisms just in case
you actually have to go out and do something
with it.
Then suppose the problem is not with the drive
unit but that one of these latches get jammed
up.
This is actually a tube cutter.
It is a little hard to see.
I don't know if you are familiar with the
things.
They are on a ratchet.
And, as it gradually cuts, you push the blade
in bit by bit.
And then eventually you cut away.
And this gives you an idea that they just
gave us a lot of tools, a pin extractor, a
crowbar, vice grips, you name it.
How much did that crowbar cost?
Well, the crowbar probably cost about $10
at Sears.
And then they had to put on all of the Velcro
and the tethers to go in the tool thing, and
that probably cost a few hundred dollars.
And then they had to make a drawing of it,
and you know how it goes.
EVA is very expensive because everything has
to be custom made.
I mean that is one of the things that, because
of the constraints of the suits and the gloves,
you cannot, in most case, just use regular
tools.
And, as I say, everything is tethered.
And I will show you pictures later.
We have a little mini workstation.
They built little receptacles on the side
of the suit because it is a hard upper torso
which can take a certain amount of load.
And so you plug basically a tool caddy into
your suit.
And then you hang all of these tools on the
tool caddy.
And you will see some pictures later of how
that works.
If the motors don't work and you have now
freed the doors so that the door can move
but you have no motor to drive it, now we
have a mechanical winch and a rope on it.
And I'm not making this up.
You actually run the rope up.
These are the little bollards that the latches
catch onto.
You run the rope up over that and then you
have to crawl out on the payload bay door,
which would be a lot of fun, and attach it
here.
And then you actually wind it closed.
And we do this in the water.
I mean this is all fully mocked up.
Yeah.
What do you do if you have trouble opening
the doors just after launch?
Well, if you cannot open the doors then you
come home.
You wouldn't want to.
I mean if there was something seriously wrong
with the doors you better come home.
Yeah, we can do this to get them closed.
But you don't want to purposely put yourself
in that situation if you know you have a problem
beforehand.
Yeah.
[NOISE OBSCURES]
We think it could be done with one person.
Normally, we only go out with two.
But in the orbital flight test, the first
four flights only had two crew members.
Was of them was EVA trained.
And then what happens if you get the doors
closed by the latches don't latch?
They actually made latches that we could put
on by hand.
These are the latches for the side.
And this is the schematic that sort of show
the latches going on the orders in that order
one, two, three and four.
And, again, the way they designed this so
that they actually close in sequence but you
only have one drive unit is really just a
beautiful mechanical system.
But if they don't close then you take this,
and I won't go into the details, but you have
to spring it around at least two of those.
And that will give you the structural strength
to come home.
And then if the center line latches don't
close, again, you can look at the mechanism
here.
And they have yet a different tool.
Now, this is actually shown on its side, but
this is actually on the top.
And this is a bitch in the water because,
yeah, your suit is weightless but the tool
is not.
And so you are holding this tool.
When you're holding the tool you want to sink
to the bottom, and so you are trying to hold
on with one hand.
And you have a tether so you try to tie yourself
to the top there so that you're kind of hanging
on the tether.
But then, depending on how your weigh out
is, if you move this big tool back and forth
your body is sort of rocking back and forth.
And you are working above your head.
I mean everybody has to do it.
If you are going to be an EVA crew member
and you cannot do this job you are disqualified.
But nobody likes it.
It is a real pain.
That is basically how EVA got sold to the
Shuttle System.
I will show you a few pictures of general
EVA activities to give you an idea of how
the system works.
And then I want to go into the question of
the interaction between EVA and the pressurization
and the environmental control system of the
rest of the Shuttle because, again, this is
a systems engineering problem.
And you cannot, in most cases, do one thing
without it having an impact on something else.
I talked about doing all this training.
Now we are stepping ten years into the future
so that is training for the Hubble Telescope.
And, actually, the telescope is so tall that
we couldn't get the whole thing in.
The pool wasn't deep enough so we had to actually
cut it in half, and we would work on one half
and then work on the other half.
Here is an example.
This is me installing the Wide Field/Planetary
Camera.
Now, the training, people normally see the
water tank.
You're not weightless.
You all understand that.
If you go upside down the blood rushes to
your head.
If you're holding onto tools, the tools will
fall down.
And of course you don't have these guys when
you're out in space.
Angels if you saw them out in space.
If you're moving around large objects, they
have resistance from the water, so you need
to get a sense of how easy it is to push things
around so you don't get things moving too
fast.
We also train on air bearing floors.
This is a mass model of the Wiff-Pick.
The same mass, moments of inertia.
And I am up here on a weight relief system.
And you can really get a sense of what it
feels like.
And so you are trying to build a kind of muscle
memory so that when you get in space you are
not trying to push things as hard as you push
them in the water.
And you also remember that if you want to
stop something you also have to be able to
exert a force on it.
Whereas, in the water, all you have to do
is stop pushing.
Now we go into space and we are ready for
the EVA.
I will sort of take you through what is involved
to give you a sense of the complexity of this
system.
First of all are tools.
That is what I looked like before all the
cosmic rays made my hair fall out.
It is just one of the hazards of spaceflight.
Here you see the kind of tool caddies.
This is for a ratchet wrench.
And we had about 250 different tools.
About a hundred planned to use and the rest
were for contingencies.
And we had to take them all out.
We call this our fish stringer.
Sort of like a Portuguese fishermen.
The fisher wives hang all the fish on the
string and then hang them out.
And then we take this out on the fish stringer.
This is the airlock at launch.
And it is totally packed.
And, in fact, we had four spacesuits rather
than the normal two so there wasn't a whole
lot of room.
And the first thing is you go and you start
checking the various systems.
And then you have to unpack everything and
move it into the flight deck.
That is Story.
We went out together.
This is the hard upper torso.
This is looking down into the inside of the
spacesuit.
The back of the spacesuit there is battery
and lithium hydroxide CO2 scrubber.
The CO2 scrubber has to be replaced after
every EVA.
It is good for about 12 hours.
And normally if you're only going out once
you don't worry about recharging the batteries,
but since we were doing successive every day
EVAs we would have to take the batteries out
every night and charge them.
Take the ones that had been charged and put
them into the suits that are going to go out
the next day.
And just keeping track of which cartridges
have been used and which batteries have been
charged and how much, I mean there is a tremendous
amount of overhead effort just in managing
all of this equipment.
And we had practiced doing this a lot on the
ground, as you can imagine, before we went
up.
The morning of the EVA.
You get up early and eat as big a breakfast
as you can because you are not going to get
much to eat for the next eight hours.
These are radiation monitors.
For Hubble we were actually up at about 600
kilometers, which is as high as the Shuttle
ever goes, so we got really the highest radiation
dose that you can get on the Shuttle on a
normal mission.
It was about between one and two REMs which
is no big health problem.
But typically the dose on a Shuttle flight
at a more typical 300 kilometers is more like
tens or maybe a little over 100 milliREMs.
They did want us to take the radiation monitor.
Now we are in the mid-deck.
And when you see these pictures you get a
sense of when you're doing an EVA the entire
middeck is just full of stuff.
I mean there is so much equipment.
You've got the pants units floating over there,
plus the two extra suits and all of the auxiliary
equipment.
You try to keep things organized.
Then for thermal control, the original Apollo
spacesuits were designed for daytime use on
the Moon when it is very hot.
And, in addition, people are walking so they
are putting a lot of metabolic heat into the
suit.
And so they were very concerned about being
able to have sufficient cooling.
They developed a very, very efficient sublimator
cooling unit.
You have a little layer of ice that is continually
fed from the bottom and it is sublimates.
That basically is how you get rid of your
heat.
And then you run your cooling water underneath
that ice and it cools off.
And then it is run through what they call
LCVG, liquid cooling and ventilation garment
which has lots of Tygon tubing that goes through
it so that it carries the cold water next
to your skin.
And also the oxygen that comes into the suit
comes through the helmet over the back of
your head so it flows over your face so you
breathe the fresh oxygen.
But you would like to get ventilation through
the entire suit so you don't build up lots
of humidity in your arms and legs.
What you do is the return valve actually comes
through these air ducts.
And so the return is picked up at the bottom
of your arms and at the bottom of your legs.
That insures that the air does get circulated
through your arms and legs.
But when we started doing Shuttle EVAs metabolically
you are not nearly as stressed.
Plus, you spend almost half your time in the
dark and it gets really, really cold.
And this has been a constant problem.
And here is an interesting systems problem
to show how everything relates to one another.
We were very concerned about when you open
up the doors of the Hubble Telescope, if direct
sunlight comes in, it will cause an out-gassing
of the internal material which could pollute
the ultraviolet mirrors.
The ultraviolet optics are very, very sensitive
to organic contamination, so under no circumstances
could we have sunlight penetrating the interior
of the telescope.
But we were going to be spending a lot of
time with the doors open, so how do you insure
that you will never get the sun coming in?
Well, the Hubble Telescope is sitting up here
like this.
If that is the sun, just make sure that the
belly of the orbiter is always pointed towards
the sun.
Then you never have to worry about sun coming
into the telescope.
But what you do have to worry about is that,
well, during the dayside of your orbit, if
the sun is over here and the earth is over
here, during the day your payload bay is going
to be pointed towards the earth.
And so, you basically have a radiative heat
exchange with something that is at about 20
degrees C.
No big deal.
If you go around the other side now, you at
nighttime, you're pointed at deep space.
And so you're radiating towards absolute zero
or three degrees Kelvin.
And that is a concern.
And you get very cold.
They were predicting temperatures of as much
as 150 below zero Celsius.
We were very concerned not only were our hands
going to get cold but some of our tools might
not work.
We pushed very hard for a test in a thermal
vacuum chamber.
Our tools are stored in a toolbox outside
in the cargo bay.
And we wanted to go through going out and
taking the tools out.
And, of course, they are held in there because
they have launch locks so there are little
pit pins and latching mechanisms that you
have to remove so that you can get the tools
out.
I went in to do the first test.
And it is a vacuum chamber.
And the walls are painted black.
And they can run liquid nitrogen through the
vacuum chamber.
And they could cool it down to the lowest
temperatures that we were expecting to experience.
I opened up the toolbox and about 75% of the
tools the launch release mechanisms were just
frozen shut.
I couldn't get them out.
So, that started to get people's attention.
They sent the engineers in to redo some of
the tolerance.
They played around with the lubrication a
little bit.
Then Story went in a week later to do his
run and he was able to get most of the tools
out.
I think he got all the tools out, actually,
because I was only in for a few hours.
Because once we realized that it wasn't working
I came out.
He was in there.
I remember he said at one point just holding
onto these tools my hands are really, really
cold.
I don't know.
About an hour or so later someone asked him
how his hands were.
He said oh, they are fine, they've warmed
up.
Well, Story is from the South.
Those of you with experience in winter know
that if your hands are really cold and after
a while you don't feel them anymore, it doesn't
necessarily mean that they have warmed up.
When they took him out of the chamber his
hands were deep purplish black and he had
severe frostbite to the point where they sent
him up to Alaska to some frostbite specialists.
In the end, he was very fortunate.
He got off with no major permanent damage
and was able to fly.
But, as you can imagine, that got serious
management attention.
So, gloves now have electrical heating units
in them.
But we didn't have that available.
What we had to do was to change the attitude
profile so that we were basically pointing
towards the earth.
Now, that is generally OK.
If you are pointing towards the earth and
the sun is coming from your belly you are
not going to hurt the Shuttle, but a quarter
way around the earth you do have the possibility
now that the sun is going to hit the telescope.
What they had to do was to do two attitude
maneuvers every orbit in order to basically
keep us in a more benign thermal attitude
for the EVA.
But to prevent the sun from shinning on the
telescope.
And we didn't the reaction control system
propellant budget to support that.
Remember we were going into a high orbit which
meant we needed to use a lot of OMS fuel to
get up there?
And we needed a lot of propellant for the
deorbit because the higher you are the more
you have to burn to get down.
And so the flight control community, together
with the pilots got together and developed
a special way that we could do maneuvers using
only half the number of jets that you normally
use.
And so this is an interconnection between
the thermal environment of EVA and the reaction
control propellant budget which nobody in
the early days of flight planning would ever
have believed that there is this sort of connection.
But it is just another good example of how
these systems all play with one another and
you cannot make changes in one without another.
I am going to finish this unit and then we
will take a little break and then I will do
the last part.
The process of getting in the suit.
First you get in LTA, lower torso assembly,
basically the pants.
And, of course, this is one time when you
can put your pants on both legs at a time.
You cannot do that too often.
But, again, look at the middeck here.
It is full.
This, by the way, is the escape pole.
We talked about this earlier.
During launch and entry it is actually bolted
into position so that it will take you out
the door, but once you are in orbit you just
sort of float it up and out of the way and
it just kind of Velcroed to the ceiling.
And, of course, it has no weight up there
so it is perfectly happy.
You get in the pants.
Now, the upper torso of the suit is attached
to the wall inside the airlock.
Now you have to float into the airlock.
And that is what you're looking at when you're
getting into the suit.
There are a lot of connections you have to
make.
This is the water bag.
This is the comm.
connection for your Snoopy cap.
This is the water and air connection which
you have to hook into your LCBG.
And these are the arms that you have to get
into.
And the problem in the design here is your
shoulders are wider than your chest.
When you are actually inside the suit you
want the distance between these two arms to
be conformal with your armpits.
Because, if it is out here that cuts way down
on your mobility.
But if it is too narrow you cannot get into
it.
That is the basic design problem in this sort
of a suit.
Now, the Russians have a rear entry suit that
doesn't have that problem.
It is always a challenge and you really have
to push and struggle to get in.
Eventually they wanted to design this suit
so that one person could get in by themselves,
but it cannot be done.
I mean you can get in like this but you just
cannot pull up the waist ring and attach it
by yourself.
Nobody has been able to do that.
It is a great feeling of accomplishment when
you finally get inside.
Then you put your helmet on.
Now you're starting to see what we are dealing
with because we have to take all this stuff
outside in addition to the tools that are
already outside.
These are the plugs which we put the mini
work station.
We haven't put it on quite yet but it is just
a whole bunch of equipment which you have
to manage.
At this point we purge the suit with an oxygen
flow.
Now, remember, we are at an atmospheric pressure,
or almost an atmospheric pressure, I will
get into that later, of pure oxygen, so that
also puts very serious flammability constraints.
Although, when you go outside, you are only
at 4 psi.
When you are inside here you are at the full
cabin pressure.
Actually, in order to do your leap check you
have to go to 4 psi above cabin pressure.
You are actually working at above one atmosphere
of pressure of pure oxygen, so that is a very
serious flammability design constraint.
And we have to sit and breathe pure oxygen
then for about 40 minutes to get the nitrogen
out of our blood.
And, again, I will be discussing this whole
atmospheric and bends problem.
But, if you don't, when you drop down to 4
psi, the nitrogen in your blood bubbles out
and you get the bends, just like a diver who
comes up too fast from a dive.
Just one or two pictures of what went on outside.
There is Hubble.
I was changing some fuels there.
It was kind of neat working underneath the
solar panel.
Those were the old ones which we took off
and replaced the next day.
But you have to be really careful because
you don't want to bang against it.
And, of course, you cannot see above your
head, so we always have other people looking
at us.
This is the kind of situation where if you
had a little heads up display where you could
get this sort of a view to show what you're
really doing it would really improve your
situational awareness.
But, at the moment, we don't have that.
It takes not just the people outside but the
people inside paying full attention, reading
procedures.
Historically, we carried all of our procedures
on a cuff checklist, like so.
But the procedures for Hubble and some of
the other flights are so complex that you
just cannot do it.
So, nowadays, these are just emergency procedures.
I will pass this around.
I would like it back.
Let's see.
After putting in the new Wiff-Pick, ground
had to do some tests on it, so I got Claude
to fly me out over the arm.
And we had one of the old Lunar Hasselblad
cameras which they let us carry.
Normally, we just use Nikons on the Shuttle,
but they let us take a Hasselblad.
That gives a view of what the payload bay
looks like EVA.
Here is Story over here working on one of
the other things.
The Earth is not flat, don't worry about the
picture.
I went around it many times.
And, I mean, some parts of EVA, I really should
share it because it just gets really spectacular.
This is about 50 feet, I don't know whether
to say above or below or whatever of the Shuttle,
but you're just out there in the middle of
nowhere.
And, at this point, I was the free-floater.
One of the people is always attached to the
end of the arm, which is good when you have
to move around big pieces of equipment because
now you can react the forces with your feet.
When you are a free-floater either you're
in a foot restraint, which limits your mobility,
or one hand has to actually be holding you
so that you can react forces.
Of course, we are attached by a waste tether,
which is then attached to a long real of stainless
steel.
But you can set it so that the springiness
is taken out.
And so I could basically, and I did from time
to time, must sort of let go.
And it is a really neat feeling because once
you convince yourself that you're not going
to fall down, which I'm enough of a physicist
to understand the orbital mechanics, but,
nevertheless, the first time I let go it was
an interesting feeling.
The thing is when you're holding onto something,
whether by your feet or your hands, of course
the Shuttle is so much more massive that you
feel yourself physically related.
You are controlled by the Shuttle.
And so the Shuttle is your point of reference.
Maybe the Shuttle is in orbit but you are
attached to the Shuttle.
As soon as I let go, the physics totally changes.
And it was really this transformation into
being a human satellite.
I mean I really felt like I was a satellite
now.
I wasn't attached to the Shuttle.
And sometimes, if I could turn around before
I let go so I didn't see the Shuttle, it was
really kind of neat, especially at night,
just sort of floating there and all the stars
and everything.
Yeah.
Do they build in time for you to be able to
kind of do that kind of thing?
No, they don't build in the time.
But, like in this case, two days before on
Story's and my last EVA we had replaced -- Not
replaced.
These are the magnetometers up at the top.
The gross maneuvering of Hubble is done by
reaction wheels, but the reaction wheels,
when they get spinning too fast, you have
to be able to desaturate them so they have
magnetic torquers, these long torque rods
which create a magnetic field.
There are no jets on Hubble because it would
cause pollution of the optics, so you need
magnetometers up at the top to sense the magnetic
field in order to operate the torquers.
The magnetometers were never designed to be
replaced.
They weren't supposed to fail.
Well, both of them failed in the first couple
of years.
We couldn't take them off so they designed
two new magnetometers that we could actually
insert and bolt on, on top of the old ones.
And then we took the electrical and data connections
and hooked them up.
But I noticed on that day -- We were very
concerned with quality control.
First of all, that we didn't break anything
that wasn't already broken but also to look
for any signs of damage because, you know,
this was a telescope that was supposed to
be maintained.
We saw a little bit of paint chipping off
the outside of the old magnetometers.
They were concerned that they might float
around and get into the optics.
We went into the payload bay the next day,
the other EVA team, and they cut off some
of this gold insulation material from one
of the thermal enclosures that some of the
equipment was in.
And I'm not supposed to stand in front.
I keep forgetting that.
We made those covers, and then we had to go
up and install them.
But, actually, after we installed them then
the ground wanted photographic documentation.
We took pictures.
And then the crew inside got their telephoto
lenses and they took a lot of pictures.
And then they got the television camera on
the end of the arm to take pictures.
And so, during all that time, you do have
a little bit of free time just to sort of
enjoy the environment.
It would be a shame not to because it is such
a spectacular place.
Yeah.
How do you work when there is not light when
you're on the dark side.
Let me turn the laser pointer on here.
Oh, no, what did I do?
That is a good time for a break, right?
Take a two-minute break.
And then, of course, when the sun rises you
know it so you can turn your lights off.
OK.
I talked about the necessity of doing a nitrogen
purge and pre-breathing oxygen to get the
nitrogen out of your blood.
This turns out to be an interesting systems
problem because it doesn't just affect the
suit, it affects the spacecraft.
Those of you who were here at the beginning
saw I was blowing up a balloon which unfortunately
popped.
It was only to make the point that you can
look at a spacesuit, the arms and legs, cylindrical.
It is like one of those balloons.
And when you try to bend the balloon it doesn't
like to stay bent because you are compressing
the gas and you're doing elastic work on the
material of the balloon and it wants to snap
back.
And spacesuits basically work the same way.
The old-fashioned pressure suits that test
pilots used to wear, which were the genesis
of the original Mercury suits, they basically
stiffen you.
And, in fact, the launch entry suits that
we use on the Shuttle are not designed for
joint mobility.
They are just pressurized.
And we do a pressure check before the mission
when we're getting suited up.
And they blow it up and you just go like that.
You can move a little bit, you know, enough
so that if you're sitting in your seat with
a seatbelt holding you in form so that your
waist is bent, you can move your arms enough
to get to the controls.
But I certainly wouldn't want to try and go
out and do any useful work in that.
It has really been an extraordinary design
process that people have been able to develop
spacesuits with articulating joints.
I mean it is certainly not like walking around
and doing things just with your body, but
it is amazing how flexible spacesuits are.
And it is a continual challenge to develop,
particularly for the gloves.
And, when we get back to the moon, to have
legs that can actually walk in so that you
don't have to hop around all the time.
Although, there are times when that is good,
too.
But, in any case, the stiffness of the suit,
because it turns out that most of the stiffness
comes from compressing the gas, you want to
try, first of all, to build articulated joints
that don't change their volume.
And, actually, people have designed metallic
suits that look like Robby the Robot.
So, they truly are zero delta volume suits.
The problem is they are very heavy and there
are other problems with metallic suits.
And I don't have time to go into that.
Given that you're going to have some volume
change, the amount of work that you do is
thermodynamically pressure times volume.
You are going to have a delta V.
You want to reduce the pressure.
The lower your suit pressure, the easier it
is to bend.
Basically, you don't want to fill your suit
with any gas that you don't really need.
We certainly don't need nitrogen to stay alive,
not on a short-term basis, so we fill the
suit with oxygen.
And we run it at about 4.3 psi for the Shuttle.
This is just historically Mercury, Gemini
and Apollo, the suit pressure was a little
bit lower.
Doctors felt, after doing calculations, what
you're really interested in is the partial
pressure of oxygen in your blood.
And they wanted a little bit more margin.
Since the Shuttle was supposed to be operational
this and operational that, they wanted a little
bit more margin.
And so we bumped up the suit pressure a little
bit.
Mercury, Gemini and Apollo cabin was 100%
oxygen at the same pressure so that you didn't
have to worry about pre-breathing.
In Skylab, it was not pure oxygen but it was
a high enough oxygen that, again, they didn't
have to worry about pre-breathe.
It wasn't until we went to the Shuttle, which
typically the Shuttle is at 14.7 or 100 kilopascals
normal atmospheric pressure.
If we know we are going to be doing a lot
of EVAs, and I will talk about this later,
what we do is we drop the overall cabin pressure,
but we keep the partial pressure of oxygen
the same so you end up bumping up the oxygen
concentration.
We don't do that with the ISS.
The decision was made by the life scientists
that since they wanted to study biology on
the Space Station and all of our database
is at one atmosphere, that if they took the
Space Station down to 10.2 psi basically it
would invalidate all of their life science
research.
So, the Station was only designed for one
atmosphere.
The operational people, when they started
to talk about how much EVA was going to be
involved in building and maintaining the Space
Station, the astronauts said this is crazy.
And you will see the impact of this later.
This is just looking in the future.
These are decisions that are going have to
be made for future space systems, and they
are looking at a lower working pressure.
And you will see why as I go through this
presentation.
I think I'm not going to go through those
charts.
Again, this is a system.
So, you are affecting a great many different
things.
Let's see.
Which is the laser here?
There we go.
One of the interesting things here with EVA,
just like in any ECLS system, is that the
human body becomes one of your subsystems
that you have to take care of.
And, in many cases, we don't have a whole
lot of design flexibility with our bodies
because they come predesigned.
So, we have to deal with that.
We have all of the physiology, the bends.
Materials.
I talked about flammability in a pure oxygen
environment.
I talked about the constraints of microgravity
and partial gravity physiology studies in
the ISS.
Of course, NASA has decided that we don't
need to do that anymore.
And, I guess, our international partners are
still going to want to do this.
In any case, the Station is designed.
The cooling we talked about, I think, in the
ECLA section lecture, the fact that if you
drop your cabin pressure now you've got to
pump more air for all the air cooled things.
And if you really want a design for a variable
cabin pressure then that flows over into the
cooling requirements, more water cooling,
different fan requirements and so on.
And it goes on.
If you are going to do multiple EVAs, what
you're really interested in, when you're looking
at efficiency, is what we call EVA Work Efficiency
Index.
It is the total amount of time involved in
preparing for and carrying out an EVA, the
ratio of that to the actual useful working
time you get outside.
And the more time you have to spend breathing
pure oxygen to denitrogenate your blood, that
is taking away from your overall work efficiency.
When we do tests on the ground and we start
out at normal sea level pressure and we want
to go down to 4.3 psi pure oxygen, we actually
have to do a four hour nitrogen purge.
We have to just sit in the suit or stand in
the suit for four hours, this is in the EVA
test chambers, before we actually can go down
to pressure.
If you want to get an eight hour work day
of EVA, that is just unacceptable.
And that is why they made the decision to
lower the Shuttle's cabin pressure.
Then you only have to do about a 40 minute
EVA.
And I have some of the specific numbers on
that later.
As I say, just the review here is that we
do have this capability on the Shuttle.
We don't have it on the Station.
They have figured out a few ways to make the
denitrogenation process a little bit more
efficient on the Station, but it is still
a big overhead hit.
And we are very concerned for the future because
EVA is not just an afterthought when you're
going to be exploring on the Moon or Mars.
You are going there basically to do EVA.
Otherwise, why bother?
We have got to deal with this.
Here is the basic physiology that we are dealing
with.
Oxygen percentage on the abscissa, total pressure
on the ordinate and all different units.
Millimeters of mercury, psi, and I think now
people use kilopascals, which I don't really
relate to.
But I know about 100 kilopascals is about
one atmosphere, so luckily that makes it easy.
Normally, we are at one atmosphere 20% or
21% oxygen, we are up here, and this is the
normal sea level equivalent.
You start dropping the pressure and you have
to increase the percentage of oxygen.
There is a maximum level of breathing oxygen
at pressure oxygen toxicity because oxygen
is almost totally absorbed through your alveoli.
And normally our alveoli stay inflated because
we have 80% nitrogen which is only very reluctantly
absorbed.
I mean it does get through, that is how it
gets into our blood and so on, but it is a
much slower transport.
But oxygen gets right through.
And if you breathe pure oxygen for a long
time you can really hurt your lungs and it
can be lethal at a certain point.
We actually don't have any good physiological
data.
I was down in Houston last week at a big EVA
conference.
That is why we didn't have class on Tuesday.
They were talking about what about long-term
planetary EVAs, even at 4 psi pure oxygen,
is that going to be harmful to health?
We honestly don't know.
I mean that is an active area which needs
research.
On the other side, of course you get into
hypoxia which you have all heard of.
You get it when you go up on Mount Everest
and so on.
So, you've got a boundary that you have to
work in.
Now, this is sort of where things have fallen.
The blue line is the hypoxic boundary.
The green line is normal oxygen.
When we were using pure oxygen spacecraft
environments, we were well above that.
You would like to stay as close as possible.
With Shuttle EVA, we moved a little bit closer
to hypoxic, but we're still in a physiologically
perfectly reasonable environment.
Decompression sickness, just a quick review.
Any scuba divers here?
You are all familiar with this.
There are various levels of decompression
sickness anywhere from just a mild tingling
of the skin to joint pain to phase three DCS
where you get central nervous system impairment
which can actually cause death, so you don't
want to mess around with it.
People refer to this famous R value.
You run into this all the time.
What you are really interested in is what
is the ratio between the actual partial pressure
of nitrogen in your blood compared to your
suit pressure?
And this over here shows this R value.
If you are down at one the nitrogen isn't
going to bubble out at all so you have no
incidence of bends.
VGE, venous gas emboli.
And then, as the R value increases, the dotted
line gas emboli, that just means you have
bubbles forming.
DCS means actual symptoms of bends.
And then grade three DCS which is very serious
indeed.
The way they make these measurements, they
have these large physiological studies where
they actually get people to volunteer to go
through these pumped down protocols.
And then they actually put sensitive microphones
and ultrasound things that can actually hear
the bubbles as they move around your veins.
I have never been able to figure out why anybody
would volunteer for these experiments.
I take my hat off to them.
Because the only way you build up this data
is that some people actually do get the bends
from these experiments.
And, of course, they have hyperbaric chambers
which, as soon as there are any symptoms,
they put them right into the chamber and pump
them to pressure and it goes away.
And I don't think that they have lost any
volunteers.
Like I say, that is not something I am going
to volunteer for.
Other factors, this is something that becomes
important.
It turns out that the amount of time you spend
at reduced pressure is important.
Also exercise.
It turns out that the more you exercise, maybe
it makes sense, you're moving your joints
around, but the bubbles come out.
Actually, what they have started to do on
the Space Station, since we cannot go to a
reduced cabin, that while they are breathing
oxygen for the first hour or so they do very
exhaustive exercise, both upper and lower
body on an exercise bike with arm exercise
as well.
To try to drive away as much of the oxygen
early on in the decompression preparation
as you can.
OK.
Where does that put us?
As I said, the more nitrogen you have in your
blood to start out with, the longer a pre-breathe
you are going to have to do before you can
go out.
These are the normoxic and hypoxic lines,
which I showed you before.
And then these are the contours of the amount
of time you have to pre-breathe.
Remember, I told you if you are at one atmosphere,
20% oxygen, your pre-breathe time is 240 minutes,
four hours.
This is to get yourself down to an R value
of 1.65.
This is not 100% safe because, remember, at
1.65, there still is a 25% incidence of DCS.
Now, the interesting thing, these are the
statistics that come from the laboratory trials,
we have never had a reported case of bends
during EVAs.
And people are not quite sure why.
Some people suspect that maybe even if an
astronaut is getting joint pain they are not
going to report it because maybe that would
prevent you from doing another EVA.
I mean there are enough other pains that you
undergo in just using a spacesuit that maybe
you don't even notice it.
You feel a problem in your joints or your
fingers and you say oh, damn, my gloves don't
fit right or something like that.
I have another slide mentioning this later.
There is some suspicion that weightlessness
may have an impact, which means that the bends
susceptibility on the Moon or on Mars may
actually be greater than it is in weightlessness.
We just don't know.
Here is where we have gotten to on the Shuttle
EVA.
Again, this is no pre-breathe, this is one
hour pre-breathe, so we are at about 40 minutes
on the Shuttle.
That is where we are.
Now, this is a design problem.
How are we going to design the CEV?
How are we going to design the equipment,
the habitats that we are going to use on the
Moon and Mars?
Now we're talking about surface exploration.
And, as I said, there is a lot of uncertainty
about the affect of gravity.
But we suspect that it may be more bends inducing
than weightlessness.
And so what they are doing for safety and
conservatism is instead of using the R value
of 1.65, which we use on the Shuttle, they
are taking it down to about 1.3, 1.4.
Now, what does that do?
Here is 1.4, 1.3.
Where does that put the Shuttle EVA we now
would have to get down to that R value?
We have got a two hour pre-breathe.
To get down to 1.3, we have got a 2.5 hour
pre-breathe.
And this is with the normal spacesuit at 4.3
psi.
We are heading an operational problem.
If you want to go out on your geology traverse
on the Moon, you have got to depressurize,
denitrogenate for 2, 2.5 hours.
I don't think so.
But what are we going to do?
Well, if you increase the suit pressure now
the R value, at a given level of nitrogen,
goes down.
And so at 6 psi, even for an R of 1.3, you
are in the zero pre-breathe range, which would
be great.
People have suggested, well, maybe we should
build a variable pressure suit so that you
could go out at 6 psi, sort of get things
set up.
And then all that time counts towards your
denitrogenation so maybe then after two hours
into your EVA now you can drop your pressure.
And now, if you have any things where you
need more dexterity, you will be OK.
But the pressure control system in a spacesuit
is a very complex undertaking.
The Russians do have a dual pressure suit.
They never used the lower pressure, to my
knowledge.
And it is a big hit to try to design this
into the suit.
And, of course, to design a suit to operate
at a higher pressure.
The Russians work at about 5 psi, but it means
your suit is less flexible, heavier and is
just going the opposite direction from the
desire to accomplish useful work, which is
why you are putting on the spacesuit in the
first place.
This is what we are working against.
Again, we have got a systems problem.
It is not just the pressure.
It is the oxygen.
In Skylab, in Apollo, because you were working
in a pure oxygen environment, now, of course,
we're talking about what is the pressure going
to be in the cabin.
You want to keep the cabin at a higher oxygen
environment.
Your material selection is highly limited.
As it says, they tended to use a lot of metallic
materials.
Well, what do we know about metals?
Particularly aluminum.
First of all, aluminum will burn at 100% oxygen.
But your cabin, even if it is not 100% oxygen,
you are going to have a lot of metallic material.
Well, metal, when you're dealing with radiation,
you hit metal, aluminum or even higher atomic
number metals with primary cosmic rays and
you get spallation.
You produce a lot of secondary particles.
And you end up with actually more radiation
than you would have gotten if you had just
gotten hit by the incident cosmic ray.
What you really prefer is to have low atomic
number.
Hydrogen is best.
Water, hydrogen, oxygen and so forth.
If you are forced to increase the metallic
content of your spacecraft because of the
oxygen flammability problems now you are going
in the wrong direction for radiation protection
which becomes an issue when you're dealing
with long duration stays on the Moon, interplanetary
transport and so on.
So, it is all interrelated.
You cannot change one thing without changing
the other.
Flammability.
Well, we have been talking about that.
I won't stay on that.
But, again, it is very dependent on oxygen.
Oxygen restricts the use of non-metallic materials.
But nonmetallic materials are what we would
like to use from a radiation point of view.
You would like to have a lot of hydrocarbons,
you know, polyethylene plastic in your spacecraft
because they absorb cosmic rays.
But, in any case, it is pretty well agreed
that we never want to go above 30% oxygen.
It just becomes too restrictive on the types
of materials we can use.
That is going to be a design constraint.
And, remember, we are aiming towards a systems
level design of our long duration space habitats
which are EVA compatible.
30% oxygen.
Now we are back to this.
Now we can draw a red line.
And we have got to stay on the left of that
line.
We have got to stay above the blue hypoxic
Now, also remember that we have got these
pre-breathe lines.
Let's say we are going to limit pre-breathe
to no more than one hour.
Well, we are cutting down on our design space
here.
We have got the oxygen flammability which
is cutting off to the right.
We have got the hypoxic limit which is cutting
off in this direction.
And we have got the pre-breathe limit which
is cutting off there.
We are kind of in a, I won't call it a box,
a rather small triangle.
Now, if we go to a 6 psi spacesuit, as I said,
we open up the design space a lot.
But at a price of flexibility, maneuverability
and the ability to do the things that we want
to do in the first place.
Where are we going to go with this?
As I say, it is an active area of research.
I cannot tell you what the answer is going
to be but it looks like they are going to
probably be going for 8 to 9 psi with an oxygen
concentration approaching 30%.
And that the CEV, from what I have been told,
is most likely going to be designed with a
variable pressure capability because it also
has to be able to dock with the Space Station
which means it has to be able to take one
atmosphere.
And also, because the CEV by itself is not
going to have an airlock, if you would have
to do an emergency EVA out of the CEV, for
whatever reason, you are going to have to
depressurize like we did back in the Gemini
days, or Apollo.
And, of course, that is going to affect the
design of all the other systems on the CEV
because they will have to be able to operate
from a vacuum all the way up to one atmosphere.
Just in the end, I hope what you have gotten
out of this is, again, we are trying to look
at things from a systems engineering point
of view.
And this is one big system where EVA cannot
be considered just on its own.
I gave an example of how it affects the RCS
system with Hubble.
Here it affects the environmental control
life support.
Flammability, radiation protection, it is
all linked together.
This was the recommendation that we came out
with, slightly below 9 psi pushing 30%.
But, as I said, there is a lot of research
that has to be done to understand the way
bends behave at partial gravity.
How we are going to do that?
I have no idea.
As I said, for the International Space Station,
we have to be able to go up to regular atmosphere.
We were making this presentation as part of
the study we were doing last year on CEV,
but it was so relevant to what we did here
that I didn't see any point in modifying it
for this class.
But we had to make these decisions on the
Shuttle based on similar calculations looking
at the design space.
The difference was with the Shuttle we were
using an R value of 1.6, 1.7.
And so we were able to get down to a 40 minute
pre-breathe.
What we do with the Shuttle is about the day
before you are going to do your first EVA
you actually drop the cabin pressure.
And when we had the lecture on environmental
control, remember there is a cabin pressure
controller at 14.7 and a pressure controller
at 8 psi.
But when they designed the Shuttle, nobody
was thinking about EVA or about this pre-breathe
time.
And so, there is no 10.2 controller.
We have to do that manually.
You drop it and then you add a little bit
of nitrogen or a little bit of oxygen, depending
on what the instrumentation tells you you
need.
And then there is a periodic maintenance which
you have to perform in order to keep the proper
gas concentrations.
And then we leave it down there for the duration
of all the EVAs.
And then, when the last EVA is finished, then
you turn the 14.7 controller back on.
Now, of course, since you have the proper
oxygen partial pressure, most of the gas that
comes into the cabin is nitrogen.
And, actually, I think we may have mentioned
this before, it comes in the bathroom.
And so, for the time when you are re-pressurizing
the cabin, the bathroom is off limits.
And I think that is basically it.
The timing has been pretty good.
Questions?
Comments?
Yeah.
Is anybody looking at using a fully one atmospheric
spacesuit?
Actually, it turns out there is a principle
called holdings principle.
Let me get this up because I have some pictures
of what we were doing.
If you change by less than a factor of two
you don't get the bends.
This is an empirical finding.
And so, the idea was if you could have a suit
that worked at about 8 psi you would have
a zero pre-breathe suit.
And I participated in a bunch of tests.
These are some other robotic things.
This was the hard suit designed by Ames.
Because it is a constant volume suit it is
not sensitive to the pressure the way that
a soft suit is.
And we did a lot of tests, actually.
We always came unstuck on the gloves.
Nobody has been able to design an 8 psi glove
that really gives you sufficient mobility.
I mean it is a dream.
People would love to be able to do it.
If we could figure it out that would solve
all these problems.
Although, if you are going to Mars maybe you
don't want full pressure because if you have
one atmosphere compared to 8 or 9 psi your
structure has to be that much thicker and
heavier.
They went through some of those calculations.
This is now on the hand with the Space Station.
And they figured that for all the meteorite
shielding and everything they had to put on
the outside of the Space Station that actually
the change in thickness that would be involved
in changing the pressure from one atmosphere
to another really wouldn't make that much
of a difference.
All of these things, again, they are interrelated.
But it is a good point.
That is why I showed those designs for 6 psi
because people are still thinking suppose
we could design a spacesuit to work at a higher
pressure.
But right now we don't know how to do that.
I hope everybody has a very happy Thanksgiving.
We will see you a week from today.
And if there are any questions, again, about
either your oral presentations or the written
presentations, I will be here today.
And then I am gone for the rest of the week,
but I will be looking at emails so you can
send me emails and we can discuss things.
OK.